what is going on everybody and welcome
to part 4 of the air hockey with robotic
arm series in this tutorial what we're
gonna be covering is how to take this
robotic arm and now that we know where
the puck is and we can generally know
where the arm is or at least tell the
arm where to go how could we actually
play air hockey now this is just going
to be a kind of proof of concept idea at
this stage I this won't be the greatest
logic ever but basically what I what I'd
like us to do is take you know we know
what the arms ranges it goes let's say
the Y goes from a negative 220 to a
positive 220 so we could take that range
and then if we know where the puck is on
the playing field we could say okay the
puck is at you know eighty percent why
well we can send the arm to its eighty
percent Y position so we could always at
even as the puck is coming down we can
always just kind of match the puck and
then once the puck crosses over a
certain X threshold let's say we could
attempt to strike the puck okay so then
we just kind of go forward and back and
that's it so the first version of this
that I came up with worked in the
following way so first of all we import
the API and all that and then also time
because we're gonna use it and then I
created the value for the arm ymax
because we we're going to need that one
then we need to access the arm as we
always have so I have this block here
where with the whole com for permission
error nonsense that we were getting oh
and then also after that we'll also go
ahead and get the device info we're
gonna set the pump to true and then
we're also gonna set a nice starting
position the pump helps to hold on to
the little striker but it's not ideal
I'm not sure if I'm going to use there's
also the little gripper thing I might
change to using the gripper rather than
pump but it's actually very challenging
because you you want like a perfect
amount of force being applied downward
to the little striker if you have too
much force you're gonna lose it like
you're gonna drop the striker and if you
have too little force the puck actually
goes goes right underneath it and I've
had that happen a lot so it's actually
I'm having a very difficult time finding
the nice sweet spot there I wish there
was almost like some sort of pressures
because that's how you play it like when
you play air hockey you know how hard
you should be pressing that striker down
as you move around whereas the arm just
has no idea so so that's actually become
quite a challenge but I'm wondering if I
actually don't use the suction cup and
instead use that a little gripper it
might actually make a whole lot more
sense so I'll probably move to that but
I think will at least get through this
tutorial doing it this way so anyways we
set the pump to true sometimes it
detects that it got it and then
sometimes it doesn't
now the other thing that we're gonna go
ahead and do let me think
so we access this we go through so in
the other code I actually have it
tracking when it recently took a swing
because like if it attempts to hit the
puck but the puck is in some other
location it'll almost always immediately
attempt based on our logic so I had a
little bit of a counter that I just made
that basically if it just if it just
swung at the puck don't swing again
immediately so so that was kind of the
idea there now coming down to the actual
logic here
just let's see so after the X&Y average
we print them out we don't really need
to print those anymore so then what I
did is get the actual percentage of the
you know where the puck is located so we
want to know the height and width of the
actual image after it's been cropped so
we just grabbed the shape of that and
that shape returns the height the width
and channels so we grab that and then we
get the X&Y positions relatively as a
percentage and then we're just
multiplying them by a hundred here so
it's a full percentage then we're gonna
print those out no problem
and then to calculate the Y location
I think I'll actually write this one out
since it has a lot of variables so let's
just say desired arm Y and I'm gonna say
that's equal to whatever the puck Y
location is due we're gonna divide it by
a hundred again to get it into a value
that we actually are hoping for so we
want to take that right so we want that
that percentage in decimal form then we
want to take that multiply it by the the
arm Y max but we don't want to
necessarily multiply that by 220 right
because the actual range itself is
actually twice of whatever the Y max is
because it goes into the negatives as
well so we're actually going to multiply
our my max by two so we're going to say
we actually want that percentage right
so we want that percent times whatever
that Y double the Y max and then when
we're all done we subtract arm well I
can just use this my max from it so it's
back into the whole negative 220 to
positive 220 but in order to apply the
percentage to that range this is the way
I'm doing it I'm sure there's a more
elegant way I just don't know it so
anyway so then what we're gonna do is
we're just set the position so I'm just
gonna copy that too so the paste so then
we're just saying the desired Y position
just so we can see that that's a number
that we expect it again it should be
between negative 220 and positive 220 if
that's not a value that we're seeing
there we have a problem also we're going
to calculate since the last time that we
made any swing and we're just going to
keep outputting that just so I can see
that too for debugging purposes
now if the pucks position is that
greater than right because this one
again they're in whole numbers not
decimal percentage so if the pucks
position is greater than 80 what do we
want to do well what we're gonna want to
do here is basically take a swing at the
actual puck but we also want to make
sure the time since we last swung is
more than twenty questions ago basically
because it's not really 20 frames
necessarily it is 20 frames but we don't
have like a steady frame rate in this
case so it's just 20 20 units yeah
okay so then it will take a swing and
that's it and we're using speed of the
whole 1 million and all that so this was
basically the exactly the you know the
first example of the program so I'm
gonna wait hopefully you set itself
hopefully you can hear it I'm gonna go
plug in the board and gonna fix the puck
a little bit just a second
okay then let's pick that region here to
hear good enough and tur and for some
reason it seems to kind of time out from
time to time I'm not actually certain
why I think it's actually the arm is
holding us up I'm not 100% on that but I
think it's actually the arm so you'd
want to tweak the time out but anyways
let me see I think the arm is timed out
again and now it's just getting in our
way oh the other thing I need to do I'm
sorry nobody can see the arm have dumb
and it's time dad again
so we definitely want to time out the
okay rather than waste everybody's time
let me go to a tweet I posted of see if
I can find it
of this model running because it does
have a couple of issues oh it's actually
not it's on YouTube that okay so this
was it as you can see first of all it's
kind of slow and even at its best strike
it doesn't even quite get to to the end
location that we're actually hoping for
but it's still actually you know it
follows the puck as it comes around and
then the puck got stuck there and that
was me actually hitting the puck there
that's what I was moving so fast but it
just kind of follows the puck around and
then tries to take a swing at the puck
from time to time so this one clearly is
not the most ideal it's too slow and it
would never score on an enemy because it
just doesn't hit and so because of that
it's actually kind of forced us to look
a little deeper into into the API and
getting this thing to run a little
quicker so in the next tutorial I'm
gonna touch briefly on that as far as
what we had to go through and then we're
gonna try to make a couple of changes
here as far as getting the arm to
actually go a little faster and then
also I'll get the display of the frame
so everybody can kind of see it rather
than me having to open up a video
anyways that's it up to this point kind
of pretty crude logic and the next
tutorial will still retain that fairly
crude logic just hopefully we're gonna
be a little quicker next time so anyways
if you've got questions comments
concerns whatever suggestions feel free
to leave them below if you want to
support the content Python permanent
slash support
otherwise I will see you in the next
video where we hopefully speed up this
arm just a little bit